sport can bring local kids and refugee
kids together this project in Berlin is
staffed by young volunteers keen to
promote integration and help newcomers
adjust to life in Germany no it's a big
challenge but we'll mashing the song
phien for me did I feel like I have
capacity to spare and I want to do
something to help on it fallout shelters
many young Germans feel that way
according to the shell study they're
more worried by xenophobia than by
foreigners in their midst that
represents a shift a 2006 study in the
same series found that fifty-eight
percent of young people wanted to see
less immigration and only 5% more this
year thirty-seven percent want to see
less immigration and fifteen percent
more aspects than younger people are
becoming more often and more diverse and
they appreciate democratic values
Democrats who sheds and vice according
to the new study youngsters are not
self-absorbed and a political as is
often claimed but increasingly
optimistic and keen to shape the future
through political activity and civic
engagement